[SPEAKER_00]: For the Wealsun, Jude, who stayed behind at the Alchemist's place, Varen, the Alchemist, and Jude, wait for the return of Paul Rivero with his
[SPEAKER_00]: Book of inscriptions on the chemical compound that kills sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, as the DM, I need to remind Jude that Jude took a sample of sahuagin gill.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cut it out of the sahuagin body to be able to
[SPEAKER_00]: Investigate what this stuff did.
[SPEAKER_00]: At first you thought it was for creating a potion of water breathing, but you think maybe this guy may know a little more about what this shit did to the sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so then I...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want to nerf your
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just wanting to remind you of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, I need that, I need that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what I'll do is after Paul Rivera leaves, I'll ask Vera and I'll be like, you know, I took a sample.
[SPEAKER_00]: Make a conversation?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would a sample of a sahuagin gills, I cut some out that had actually died.
[SPEAKER_01]: I originally thought that I would maybe try to make a potion of water breathing, but then I realized that it might be actually a corrupted sample because the sahuagin that I took the gills from actually had perished from this chemical.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I didn't throw it away because I actually thought that maybe we could analyze it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that something you can do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you analyze
[SPEAKER_01]: Sahuagin Gills, where the Sahuagin died from this chemical.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you have a field test?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Give me the gills.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I bust them out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have them in the best of an alchemist.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you have a bolt in that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, a bolt.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's wet.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's moist.
[SPEAKER_01]: I kept it moist.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, you hand Viren to Gils.
[SPEAKER_00]: He opens them up.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, well, battlefield, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Battlefield.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, I can see the cutting.
[SPEAKER_00]: The knife was sharp, I assume.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was plus one.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was very sharp.
[SPEAKER_00]: He looks at it and he goes...
[SPEAKER_01]: But it was battlefield conditions.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: These gills, they seem to be particularly susceptible to this compound.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like there's a genetic coding for the compound?
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no idea what the word genetic means, but... Bloodborne.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like a bloodborne, like a sickness, where some people have a predisposition.
[SPEAKER_00]: All I can see are the damage here.
[SPEAKER_00]: How long were they exposed, do you know?
[SPEAKER_00]: It was quick.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was quick.
[SPEAKER_01]: The body of water, I give them roughly the cubic inches of the cavern, mathematically speaking.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then the amount of, and we probably poured in too much of the amount.
[SPEAKER_01]: A barrel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it was a heavy saturation.
[SPEAKER_01]: I found out later that they usually don't do even that much, even out in the open ocean borders of the island.
[SPEAKER_01]: So contained area.
[SPEAKER_00]: He says, let me look at the gills.
[SPEAKER_00]: He takes the gel and he actually puts it in a glass jar and then pours water or you have no idea what into it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hi.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hola.
[SPEAKER_00]: Clings it around and then pours it into another beaker and then takes a dropper.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's got a great, you know, he's got a great laboratory.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lots of weird kind of tubing, things like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: He drips himself in and he goes, oh, interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: He looks at you and goes... What is your name?
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude, yes, we've spoken before.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the truth, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey Elise, please, we're trying to play it here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: He says...
[SPEAKER_00]: Very interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sahuagin gills are a hundred times more susceptible, plus or minus, on an order of magnitude, than normal fish.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is, roughly, this substance would be, relatively speaking, non-toxic to most of your sea life.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's toxic.
[SPEAKER_00]: But not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Deadly.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's specifically engineered to make the hug and die.
[SPEAKER_00]: Quickly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, and quickly.
[SPEAKER_00]: They will die instantly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Instantly.
[SPEAKER_00]: If it comes into their gills.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's their life.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's the fact that sahuagin have the ability to live in water and to live in oxygen at the same time.
[SPEAKER_00]: This explains much to me and why it's so hard to understand what this compound is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because it was created in a way engineered for this race.
[SPEAKER_00]: This explains why, so if I understand what you and Paul Rivero said, this is port in the Straits of Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, and around Helms Island.
[SPEAKER_01]: It has been.
[SPEAKER_01]: It has been for many years, 20 years plus.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hundreds.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hundreds of years, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why there's still fish in the strait?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Strait of Monmurg has always been fish deficient, from what I understand.
[SPEAKER_00]: And normal fish would leave this area.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's an irritant to them, of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sahuagin, however, died instantly from this.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a very, very, very
[SPEAKER_00]: Specific poison.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it magically enhanced?
[SPEAKER_01]: Magically enhanced?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, so would there be any kind of a ritual to this component?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or is it purely a combination of mundane?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is the thing that makes it specifically attuned to affect the sahuagin, is that any kind of a magical adjuvant or
[SPEAKER_01]: So what is a blood ritual to you?
[SPEAKER_01]: What is magic to you?
[SPEAKER_01]: All living things have an energy, and it's a drawing of that energy, or at least a magical practitioner is able to draw.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where we run into forbidden magics is because it takes energy to the point of
[SPEAKER_01]: Death of everything around it.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's a forbidden magic here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, necromancy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, well, in Keoland necromancy is not forbidden.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, in Keoland necromancy is forbidden, but in the principalities it's not.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you consider forbidden?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, to me, it's all grist for the mill.
[SPEAKER_01]: As am I.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I'm not one to discuss forbidden, other than in the context of how you asked me about magic.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't personally, or at least I have not personally used any magics that draw upon any kind of entropy or taking magical energies to the point of...
[SPEAKER_01]: Destruction.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I use magic to destroy, of course, but it's still things that I pull from the air or from the world around me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, well, what I'll say to you is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: This magic is not mundane.
[SPEAKER_00]: Whatever that means, it's very advanced.
[SPEAKER_00]: But this magic is engineered in a way, and I'll say that word if you do not know what that means.
[SPEAKER_00]: Specifically to destroy the zahuagin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Constructed.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think of engineered as constructed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: This will destroy aquatic life and is inerrant to most.
[SPEAKER_01]: The reason why I ask if there was a magical component is that I've been tasked by Lord Jameis to
[SPEAKER_01]: Recreate it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if this came from the Duke of Berghof, and we haven't received any supplies for decades, I'm wondering... Oh, wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: This came from the Duke of Berghof?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the supplies...
[SPEAKER_01]: Have been raided, but the Duke of Berghof hasn't provided this material for, it's been 40 years or longer?
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: He hasn't provided this material for twenty years.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so I've been tasked by Lord Jeon and Lord Jameis to... Is it Sir Jameis?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's Lord Jameis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Jameis.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Prince Jeon, sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: By Prince Jeon and Lord Jameis to be able to manufacture this substance ourselves, here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because our supply
[SPEAKER_01]: Has been diminished greatly and we haven't received, we have not received anything for 20 years.
[SPEAKER_01]: So all of the stores that we've used to keep the sahuagin at bay come down to a very limited amount of time.
[SPEAKER_00]: His hand touches his lip and he wipes it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Doesn't have discolored lips or anything, does he?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you can tell he's disturbed.
[SPEAKER_00]: And by the way, I want to tell you, this guy's old.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's got spectacles on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is he human?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well... To the best of my knowledge.
[SPEAKER_01]: But by old, you mean like 70s?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or do you mean like... 70s.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Older than any human you've ever seen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, gotcha.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because...
[SPEAKER_00]: So, Lord Jameis and Prince Gian are involved in this?
[SPEAKER_00]: We need this, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is more than a still.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: This still that I had purchased from you, um, well, to be quite honest, it was just to make our introduction.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the still is being used.
[SPEAKER_01]: I did have a purpose for the still.
[SPEAKER_01]: But this is not, the still is not for this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, it says not, because...
[SPEAKER_01]: What is it about the Duke of Berghoff that makes you...
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a connection.
[SPEAKER_00]: He kind of turns his back to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's the connection, Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Between you and the Duke of Berghoff?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course not.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, the connection is the substance.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you understand the connection with the Duke of Burgholm?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: He looks back at you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Turns around.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have any wine?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was just asking.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a drink, anything but scotch.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a Dovan drink, and I'll bring some to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think that I should tell you some things about the Duke of Berkhoff.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is your relationship with this Paul Rivero, by the way?
[SPEAKER_01]: I am serving Lord Jameis more specifically, rather than Prince Gian.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Lord Jameis has asked me to teach him the rudimentaries of magical arts.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've only known him like Paul Rivero for probably... Well, I've never seen him without his mask on.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've only known him since I came back.
[SPEAKER_01]: I used to adventure here and I used to know Lord Jameis and work for him years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was gone to Adi on the eastern side of the Azure Bay for probably a year and a half.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you well traveled?
[SPEAKER_00]: I like to think so.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you know the name Safar Azane?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I roll a dice or do I?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless it's attached to the Scarlet Brotherhood, I don't know that I would know it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to ask that question or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just asking the DM if I actually know that, if Jude knows that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude does not know that name.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zepharo Zane does not know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then I'd just say I had some misgivings with the Scarlet Brotherhood, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, come on.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're talking about high school days.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is not high school.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, in my previous adventures, I've never come across that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, that's not some legendary... No.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not some... No.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it's not anything that I would have come across with, like, fighting the Herzog back east.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, if he's testing me on names back east.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I'd be honest.
[SPEAKER_01]: My worldly travels, if those are names from the East, we fought against
[SPEAKER_01]: To the DM, it wasn't the Herzog himself, was it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Was it the South Province?
[SPEAKER_01]: That was the Herzog in the South Province.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Great King was the Great Kingdom.
[SPEAKER_00]: You fought against the Herzog, but these two are not anything you've known about.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I just say, if you're asking me in the context of me having traveled back east, or east of the eastern Angera,
[SPEAKER_01]: Our battles were with the Herzog and fighting for Iddi.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then what was the sailor port town that my servant or my henchman came from?
[SPEAKER_01]: It was, God, I don't remember that name.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I tell him that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, I'd be open about my travels through, like, weren't we outside of even Greyhawk City?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, when we were like forming our army and such.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I mean, I'd give them, without going on into excessive great detail, I'd be forthright, I'd be honest with them.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I also admit that I had not, I do not know those names.
[SPEAKER_01]: The two names.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is the relevance for us here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, in truth, they are great transmuters that I know of that reside in Keoland and there is conflict between them.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the two names that you mentioned are opposing powerful houses?
[SPEAKER_00]: He rubs his face and kind of looks down his beard and he goes, They're both great men.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're both great men.
[SPEAKER_00]: This, he pats the gills, are the legacy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of their work?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of the work of people for them, but they carry it on as they should.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they would know, both of them, even though they're opposed to each other, both of them would know this?
[SPEAKER_00]: They're not opposed to each other from what I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're friends, but rivals.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can understand that.
[SPEAKER_01]: As good friends always are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you give me as a DM what those two names are again?
[SPEAKER_00]: Ediem Nakhond and Zafar Hazane.
[SPEAKER_00]: And both of them are Keolanders?
[SPEAKER_00]: They are both from Keoland, even though Zafar Zane has visited Monmurg frequently in his time.
[SPEAKER_00]: He comes here often.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know of Eem only through legend, as he is a great alchemist and transmuter.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've met Zafar himself.
[SPEAKER_01]: He has come to my shop often.
[SPEAKER_01]: When was the last time you saw Zafar?
[SPEAKER_01]: Two years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did he ever visit you on any kind of a schedule?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: He comes when he wishes, but I do know this.
[SPEAKER_00]: His sister is married to Lord Jameis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Zafar Zain's sister is married to Lord Jameis?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's why he visits me so often.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's a great transmuter, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I know he would know this compound.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he points to the gill with his finger.
[SPEAKER_00]: He consults with me often.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's talked to me of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who is that young man that was with you?
[SPEAKER_01]: He must not be talking about... Who would he be talking about?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not talking about Paul Burbell.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, no, not really.
[SPEAKER_01]: He didn't know who he is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I thought he knew- I thought he knew that Paul Rivera was- He did, but he's trying to actually get you to say it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gotten that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Got it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I don't have confirmation yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I've had the bastard conversation, but I actually don't know that.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's the point he's trying to make.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's like, who is that?
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not asking me because he wants to know.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's asking me because he wants to know if I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: He wants more information.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I work with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I go in that direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're saying Paul Rivera was significant?
[SPEAKER_00]: More than he knows.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've heard rumors.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he's been presented to me if Lord James is my patron and I work for him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's been presented to me, which I did find unusual that Lord Jameis would ask me to in some way mentor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Lord Jameis didn't say the word mentor, but that's what he meant.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm an elf.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm independent.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not really part of the hierarchical structure here at Monmurg, other than the fact that I've worked with Lord Jameis.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the past.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I did think that that was unusual that I would be assigned somebody that did seem important to Lord James.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mercenaries are always more trustful than those in the court.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is known.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's why you were chosen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Especially when knowledge is important.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your minds, your minds are not biased.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what rule needs, unbiased minds.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's why you were chosen, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sure of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have to be what you are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I can see that.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's given me the tower, I name whatever the tower is to this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's given it to me and it seems pretty obviously an attempt to
[SPEAKER_01]: And tie me here to Monmurg, which as a mercenary, that would make sense that he would offer me a tower.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I would love a tower, especially if it comes fully equipped with a lab and all of the other things that are necessary for my work, including solitude, and he's given me access to the library.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what you say makes sense to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: But this is still new to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I've lived my life as a mercenary, doing mercenary work, this is the first time, and I'm communicating this to you in just all honesty, this is the first time that I've come across my values being more than just a fireball.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, what does that instruct you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Say that again.
[SPEAKER_00]: What does that instruct you, that they are?
[SPEAKER_01]: They're desperate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: He points you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I go, they're desperate.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're desperate.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this proves it.
[SPEAKER_00]: He pointed the goat.
[SPEAKER_00]: This.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you look at history, 150 years ago, what saved the principalities
[SPEAKER_00]: Was the destruction of the Sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_00]: The scourge of the Azure Seed.
[SPEAKER_00]: This made them possible.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they took the battle to them.
[SPEAKER_00]: You prove it.
[SPEAKER_00]: He points to the packing of stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: This was the weapon that made them creamish.
[SPEAKER_00]: A month ago I would have been killed if I had known that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And now you say someone has taken it away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I know who.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who?
[SPEAKER_01]: Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: I killed two myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: I killed one myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: But there were two Toli involved in taking.
[SPEAKER_01]: But that doesn't still negate the fact that the Duke of Berkhoff stopped supplying this material 20 years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: 20 years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: To Prince Gian
[SPEAKER_00]: And it was their stores that were taken by the Toli.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you tell me this here now?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you trust me on this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess because I'm desperate.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess desperation flows downhill, much like shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then you're honest.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're honest.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'll tell you something more.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're in the middle of a war that has been going on for a thousand years.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the actors are...
[SPEAKER_00]: I know the sewers.
[SPEAKER_00]: The soul are involved, but there are more than that.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a conflict between reality and imagination.
[SPEAKER_01]: Conflict between... What was and what is?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is, and what is real.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I make an intelligence rule?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to know?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to know...
[SPEAKER_01]: If I can understand, so for me, the conflict has been with, like, I link this to the Sewell and the Scarlet Brotherhood and their encroachment, which to me seems very mundane, typically Sewell, arrogant, that kind of stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: When he's talking about real,
[SPEAKER_01]: It almost sounds something deep.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I would like to make an insight roll on to whether or not I can understand, not obviously all the details, but do I comprehend?
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you give me a little bit more?
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I add an intelligence bonus or is this just... No, it's intelligence.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's full spot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if I have insight...
[SPEAKER_01]: Which I do have insight, so then I get to add my plus three proficiency.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is plus three actually, I think it's supposed to be a plus four.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's plus three, your level, plus your intelligence, which is plus five, so plus eight is what your insight would be.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's talking about stuff much deeper than what you're talking about.
[SPEAKER_01]: So far he's responded to me being honest, especially with my comment about being desperate.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they're desperate, they hire me.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm desperate, I'm sharing with him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I continue and I say, I understand about the Sewell.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I understand in my interaction with the Scarlet Brotherhood that they are much more dangerous than most of the rest of the kingdoms even understand, in the sense that the Scarlet Brotherhood seeks to penetrate the kingdoms to get them to either fight against each other.
[SPEAKER_01]: To me, and I just say flatly, the Seul would love to have another Seul empire.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I think that I don't understand the ruling houses of the Sula yet, but that is one of the directions, which I told you before it's the DM that I was searching for, like, you know, like, what are the...
[SPEAKER_01]: So, do you want to ask a question?
[SPEAKER_01]: How does this go beyond that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Beyond what?
[SPEAKER_01]: What I just said about, so I related about my understanding with the Sewell and like that their desire to control everything and that their Sewell ruling houses.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it sounds like you're talking about something deeper.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you talk about something being reality?
[SPEAKER_01]: The Sewell.
[SPEAKER_01]: A race of people.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they have great houses and great history.
[SPEAKER_00]: This goes beyond that, Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I'm asking.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's because I'm stuck in the great houses of the Sewell and their efforts and their energies.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Scarlet Brotherhood were derived from a Sewell house.
[SPEAKER_00]: A lesser Sewell house.
[SPEAKER_00]: When I say lesser, what I mean is the other Sewell houses thought they were.
[SPEAKER_00]: They were greater than the Sewell houses were.
[SPEAKER_00]: The royal Sewell houses derived from blood.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Scarlet Brotherhood were derived from knowledge and ability.
[SPEAKER_00]: They are truly to be feared.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Toli are allied with them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I've made that connection.
[SPEAKER_00]: They are brother houses fighting against the royal houses of Seul, the ten houses of the bloodlines.
[SPEAKER_00]: So there's ten, he says ten?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And how do you spell Sewell?
[SPEAKER_01]: S-U-E-L.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, and I look at him and I say, and Lord Jameis' wife is one of those ten houses.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I know is this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lord Jameis' wife.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a great franchise.
[SPEAKER_00]: She's sister to Zapara Zane, who is a powerful lord in Keoland and a great transmuter.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do not know his patronage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is he?
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't know if he's a royal, one of the ten royal houses?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not known to be from one of the royal houses.
[SPEAKER_00]: The only four that exist in Keoland that I know of are the Rola.
[SPEAKER_00]: These are Sewell royal houses.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Rola.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Linn.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then the Healy.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the Ekstor that died a thousand years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: What was that called?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ekstor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ekstor?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Zafara Zane is a man that serves the role of family.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Duke of Gratzel is who he talks to.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know this.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I have talked to him many times.
[SPEAKER_00]: He is the transmuter and understands things very well.
[SPEAKER_01]: But isn't the Duke of Gretzel, isn't he the one that's fabricated the isolation of Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So imagine watching Friday the 13th was very first time.
[SPEAKER_01]: His sister is with Lord Jameis here, and he visits here, and he has.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is strange to me because the activity between the Duke of Gratzel and Monmurg, I don't believe Zephara same fully appreciates or accepts.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's tried to keep the peace.
[SPEAKER_00]: Between the cities for years.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was waylaid on my travels here on my ship by the Duke of Redshore, and the Duke of Redshore had said that the Duke of Gratzel's pretext for isolating Monmurg was slavery.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the Tolis have that under wraps, the Tolis' slavery options.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would say this to you, slavery is a pretext because Keoland is guilty of much worse.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ask yourself this, if you force someone to work for you,
[SPEAKER_00]: Plow your fields.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that worse than putting them to death so you survive?
[SPEAKER_00]: If you make a hundred thousand people plow your fields but yet kill a million to make yourself live, who is the worst criminal?
[SPEAKER_01]: The one who kills a million or the one who enslaves a hundred thousand?
[SPEAKER_00]: Look into Vangna and what Keoland has done.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did he say Vangna?
[SPEAKER_00]: Look into what the Nihili are guilty of.
[SPEAKER_00]: Look into what the Rola are guilty of.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Rolla, the Venkna, we'll look into what Venkna, and then Rolla, and what was the other one?
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a knock at the door.